what's up everyone currently in Venice
then sei in Italia and who we're
currently looking at this gun to all the
service right here these peeps are
taking the kondal of little boats
through the these channels these little
tiny river ways of the actual
Mediterranean waters because Venice all
the way on the east side of Italy the
very northeast side of Italy anyway this
is nuts because you know look at these
buildings that are that are between the
little tiny River water ways these are
spread all throughout Venice in Italy
it's gorgeous here these guys have a
monopoly on the place that gun to all
the services I was recently learning
from a couple of the nations that that
they charge like whatever 100 euros for
like a half hour on the boat which is
pretty expensive that's about like 120
100 yeah 20 ish US dollars and I was
like what happens if I just like bring
my boat from outside of the city and
drive it in and start offering a service
and they're like looking a boat burn I
was like that's a pretty intense Mafia
ideology but that kind of stuff exists
across the planet you know this sort of
territory and turf of the me versus them
and so with us versus them and I just
did a little video about that a little
earlier as well but I thought it would
be interesting to just chat about again
and and also just showcase how beautiful
Venice Italia other crazy thoughts about
the Venetians are that the Venetians
were telling me that it's now becoming
more difficult for them to retain
ownership of property here a lot of them
are moving out of Venice and they're
moving into other areas of Italy as well
as just moving around and there's you
know part of that is a natural thing but
also part of that is just like a natural
thing of people moving to different
parts of the world but also we see a lot
of that in San Francisco there's enough
time many San Franciscans left in San
Francisco in Venice you have to be a
third generation in order to be
considered Venetian so the general idea
behind that's like whoa like what's
going on with property prices you know
who's just coming in smoothing a
property from the United States Europe
China wherever I'm just coming to swoop
in a property keeping it as the third or
fourth or tenth home or whatever and
should we be having a global discussion
about what that's like when we're
affording real estate across the world
and we only live in it for 14 days out
of the year and that it's potentially
moving out the artists and the other
thinkers and doers in the area that
actually lived there and they're being
forced to go into longer commutes to and
from all this different kind of stuff so
there's so many variables to crunch
around this but are we actually
considering what it's like to drive
artists and other creative intellectuals
out of communities based on financial
variables because that that to me that
that seems like counterintuitive because
artists should be paid well artists
should be funded well designers should
be funded well people that are trying to
progress you and Crete
he should be funded well but they're not
in many ways and so if we're driving
them out of Venice we're driving them
out of San Francisco we're driving them
out of these areas due to real-estate
prices and in many cases it's not just a
family owns one property in there one
property's in Venice this is a second
third fourth fifth property type of city
and so these are just all things to
consider all variables to crunch in the
process is not as easy as just binary
black-and-white thinking I'm gonna try
and get us as far out of binary
black-and-white thinking as possible
crunch the variables think about it what
should we do about people living in
certain areas about retaining some sort
of the cultural system like again do we
want the Venetian history to also be
gone over time because people aren't
able to live here and communicate their
culture their writings their music their
art their traditions because we want to
keep that right we want to keep a
genealogy of the ideas over time you
want to be able to keep that and see
where things came from an archaeology of
ideals over time
and this is all really important to
think about and keep up with so again
consider what it's like crunch these
variables how do we keep artists and
creatives around for longer periods of
times in cities and why is that
important why is it important to retain
the archaeological genealogy of all the
culture ideas history in general and how
do we best do that so thanks for tuning
in and learning more about Venice this
place is insane highly recommend it's
like a video game being here I'm
seriously video game so come check it
out and be respectful and also be
artistically inclined and creatively
trying to talk about these things let's
figure out how to make the artists and
creatives on the planet more loved and
adored and retain more of this culture
across the planet let me know with your
thoughts below I'd love to hear some of
your thoughts about how we do that let's
start the global conversation about it
much love everyone thanks for tuning in
from the Nessie on u-value